explosive revelations regarding the
Donald Trump doing illegal business in
communist Cuba with the Fidel Castro
regime story from last week Donald
Trump's co-manager Kellyanne Conway
seemed to either accidentally or
cluelessly admit that yes the bombshell
Newsweek story last week by Kurt icon
Wald alleging that Donald Trump broke US
law by doing business in Cuba spending
68 thousand dollars they're exploring
business opportunities is indeed true
Kellyanne Conway was on ABC's The View
and she very clearly doesn't deny that
Donald Trump spent money in Cuba while
looking into business opportunities
there hurt I can Walt seems to be
exactly right on this here's Kelly Ann
on the view you determine whether this
was an accident or whether she admitted
what she thought was not a big deal
without realizing this is a major major
deal take a look at the video where I
want to ask you about a story that's
breaking this morning from the Newsweek
that one of trumps companies spent money
in Cuba during the embargo when Fidel
Castro once ago during his during his
regime the whole story but these are
serious accusations outage anything
invest in it no they're treasonous
I read the entire story it starts out
with a screaming headlines it as it
usually does that he did business in
Cuba and it turns out that he didn't he
decided not to invest there if you read
the entire are you denying method that
his company spent any money in Cuba I
think they paid money as I understand
from the story they paid money in 1998
no we're not supposed to talk about
years ago when it comes to the Clintons
but with the Trump well here's that she
can bring the rocky he's the one that I
don't believe you're allowed to spend
money unless it's a humanitarian effort
or a government effort and in that
context of you're dealing with this
particular regimes not in or of Miami
they're not gonna like that right so the
question is did
very critical of Castro and he's been
critical he gave a speech the very next
year to the Cuban American National
Foundation in Miami critical of those
who want to do business with Castro and
he's talked about the Cuban embargo even
on this on the show but again we're
talking about did his hotel invest money
in 1998 so he decided not to invest
there no denial of the fact that money
was spent there asked if she's denying
that he spent the funds she said I think
he paid the money back in 1998 that is
what is illegal that is the allegation
of the Newsweek story by Kurt I can Wald
that is against the law this is a good
opportunity for me to clarify after our
first story on this people started
emailing me saying David how can you be
in favor of the Cuban embargo it's a
disaster I've been against the Cuban
embargo for as long as I have known
about it right I remember being a little
kid and being against the Cuban embargo
this is not being in favor of or against
the Cuban embargo this is about Donald
Trump's hypocrisy on many levels at the
first debate remember he went on this
rant about law and order
he's about law and order Hillary Clinton
is not about law and order if you ignore
federal law because you want to explore
doing business in Cuba that is not law
and order and that's a separate issue
from anyone's opinion about the Cuban
embargo which I agree was always a
disaster Donald Trump has been publicly
critical of the Castro regime for a long
time he panders to Cuban American voters
but it seems really he would have been
fine doing business with the Castro
regime there's no indication that after
spending these $68,000
he didn't do business with the Castro
regime because he realized oh wait I'm
against communism and I'm against Castro
it appears that it was just a business
decision that they didn't want to pursue
this any further
how else has the Donald Trump campaign
tried to push back against this story
well Steve Cortes a trump surrogate
acknowledged the report in Newsweek by
Kurt Icahn Wald but he said if this was
a violation it was an incredibly tech
violation it is illegal to spend money
in Cuba or it was at the time Trump
spent money in Cuba is that a
technicality or is that just breaking
the law exactly as plainly written in
simple English you can decide about that
but the two most important point
important points here are the fact that
the Cuban embargo was shameful and
capricious doesn't occur in any way of
excuse the actions of Donald Trump and
number two
nobody is denying the facts of the
report from the Trump campaign they are
denying that it was recent they are
arguing that it was a technicality they
are saying that they ultimately decided
not to invest in this business but
nobody is actually denying the facts of
the story and that is really the
important thing this were were
30-something days out from the election
Florida is hugely important if Trump
does not win Florida the path to 270
electoral votes is incredibly difficult
this could have an impact no doubt about
it
Omaha Steaks sent me a great package of
steaks and it was fantastic as some of
the audience knows my girlfriend is
pescetarian so I invited over some of my
meat eating friends and we used my new
grill that I finally got now that it's
almost fall and everybody loved it it
was terrific
I kind of rather grill in the fall than
summer just less oppressively hot and
the limited time family grill pack that
Omaha Steaks is offering for just $49.99
is a really great way to do it you will
get two filet mignons two top sirloins
four boneless pork chops four
chicken-fried steaks a 12 ounce package
of all beef meatballs for Omaha Steaks
burgers for gourmet jumbo Franks a 16
ounce package of Omaha Steakhouse fries
for caramel apple tartlets Omaha Steaks
seasoning and for additional Omaha
Steaks burgers and just for my listeners
Omaha Steaks is offering all of this for
only $49.99 this is a huge savings go to
maja stakes dot-com enter my code Pakman
in the search bar and add the family
grill pack to your cart do not miss this
deal visit Omaha Steaks dot-com and
enter my code Pakman in the search bar
to get over 30 gourmet items for $49.99